happy
day today's the weekend today
specifically sunday the day that i like
to clean so i already woke up and the
first thing i did was put a load of
laundry to wash i start with the colored
clothes just because that's the one that
we have the most of that takes me the
longest that i dread the most so i try
to get rid of the stuff i don't want to
do first did that then i clean all the
sheets
off my bed and put some new ones on
so um i can start the week off with a
fresh set
then i come down to the refrigerator
and i throw away any old or expired
food
and then i'll place an order on
instacart or if not on instacart then
i'll uh
um i'll go to the grocery store and just
buy whatever essential items i need to
get the rest of the week started so
oh and
i emptied out the trash
yes
all before 8 a.m
i already feel like i'm starting off my
week on the correct foot just by already
like
cleaning all the dirtiness out
feels good already next step is putting
away
clean dishes to make room for the dirty
ones
and then
as that's happening
i'm making a bottle i'm toasting a bagel
if you guys don't understand geotalk
it's a bagel i am toasting a beagle
right now i was honestly between these
two
between raisin bread which is super
nostalgic for me and makes me feel
very warm isn't the best
in terms of flavor or quality but i just
grew up with it so
it's just it's comforting or
a bagel
and i put these in the fridge because
i've noticed they last longer my mom
always talked about this
and when i first moved out i'm like oh i
just hate hard cold bread not doing it
but then every week i was throwing it
away and then as soon as i started
throwing it out here
um or not throwing it out but as soon as
i started putting it into the fridge it
would last longer and i'm like
you're right again
my bagel's done
oh yes
warm and toasty
yes
make myself some coffee
we have oh my god
i can't believe i slammed it like that
bart and taika
are in their office
doing their thing
[Music]
yeah already had his breakfast so he
gets a little snack yup i have the most
insane club ever because um
i woke up a little bit late because i
was sleeping in his bed this morning and
it felt so comfy that was oh shut up
train so i woke up oh [ __ ] said that
joe's coming at eight you're not wearing
a watch what are you looking at
and so i was like
oh shoot joe's coming at eight
and so i'm just rushing through my
workout you know when we keep the rest
short
it's like
whoa
whoa
is it just me yeah
um so like he was saying
[Music]
he looks great i know we gotta give him
that right he's a big dude he looks
great but as a wife
it's my job to bring him back down water
to a negative you know what i mean
um
but like bart said we're gonna meet up
with joe we're gonna go on a hike today
around the area so that's fun getting
everything prepped enjoying my morning
ah it feels so good okay so got my jug
of ice cold water
my boggles plain or dry
and then my coffee so with this coffee i
love it because i get this at a korean
market back in california i haven't
checked out here if you have it but it
already comes with cream sugar and
obviously the coffee you open the pack
and you just dump it in there
and it's so good because i'm not the
biggest fan of the flavor of coffee um
i mean unless i'm eating something sweet
with it then the coffee needs to be
black because obviously the sweet thing
like they pair up really nicely but if
i'm not
then i do like some type of sweetness
but junebe sells these electric whips
um
or not whips what the hell are these
called
um
you know what i mean these electric
thingies i can't think of the word right
now whisk
whisk
not wisp not whip but whisks uh we sell
these
and that's why it looks so frothy
okay so we are now at red rock
canyon this is where
we're gonna do our hike
we're gonna do this one
the pine creek
known before okay
elevation
caution
okay flash flooding
okay
got it
this is what we're gonna do
we are here
cool
it's a cool little sign
wilderness boundary what does that mean
this is really cool
you can donate
i'm gonna donate
this is super awesome
it's right next to the
name of it
but look at this
gorgeous
this is pretty amazing seeing the
progress
of tyka's hiking skills
see look at that all by himself he can
navigate all these little rocks before i
would have to hold his hand but now i
could do it all by himself good job you
little monkey doody duty
no we can't go that way the trails this
way
gotta follow uncle joe did you see him
navigate all the rocks no i didn't all
by himself i don't know we're talking
about ricky gervais and how he's such an
epic troll yeah and what's that show the
biggest idiot idiot abroad yeah i gotta
watch it he found he has a friend he's
just dumb and he thought it would be
funny to make him the most famous man in
britain yeah and it kind of works
that rock's gonna come back at us okay
oh yeah you're gonna hit him yeah
because he doesn't know how he's letting
go he doesn't know how he's aiming so he
starts back here and it's like
right at your face
literally
wow look at that view
this is huge
[Applause]
what are you saying just the view is
beautiful
you're ruining it a little bit
so what's pretty crazy about the terrain
is behind me is what traditional like
vegas nevada looks like right like
big old rocks more desert looking
but then on this side
it's like crazy green you got pine trees
it's pretty interesting how the climate
looks
way different looks almost like yosemite
big bearish
all the way down here
so this is one of the trails that i've
been really interested in hiking because
when we're driving through red rock i
saw like the change and climb in it was
just cool that in one spot they have so
many different
habitats like look literally right here
there's a desert plant and behind
is a forest
plant hey duty are you a desert or a
forest animal
you're nothing
the pine creek canyon hey you see the
water down there yeah
okay throw a rock see if you can hit the
water
hey good
that's the whole job
fun huh
just that throwing wrong super fun
good here because you're deaf as [ __ ]
and you heard this little stream yeah
yeah we're we're walking and i was like
wait here's something i'm like is that
running water hear me when i'm telling
you to help me fold the launcher
shoot did she did he just smack you in
the face with the rocks oh he went over
her head oh my god you gotta be careful
monkey oh
be careful monkey
did you even notice me okay god up there
how's your back i got it thanks guys
dude i [ __ ] up that was my bed
and i'm sorry you're in the line of fire
i know i'm sorry for talking [ __ ]
wow you hit the water
yeah we were hiking and i'm like wait i
hear something i hear something
and then i was like oh there's running
water
and we found it so maybe we could find
some more it's so cool
hey monkey you hear that yeah the
waterfall
wow look at that
look at that
whoa
oh that gushing water right there
that's what's making all that noise
[Applause]
it's not deep are your feet cold
your feet are protecting you
okay throw it
over here over here look here look how
deep it is over there throw it over
there
that's true thank you for being so
considerate throw it that way
whoa
with me okay let me go in the water with
you
hey look at me i'm in the water too
hey we're in the water together
nope not at all baby not all baby
don't go too deep don't go too deep
what he wants over there
to action
all right so taika has been throwing
rocks at me because i want to get a cool
photo of it coming at me but now he
wants me to throw a rock at him i threw
a small one like this
and he called you a bigger one
you want a big one
okay here it comes
[Music]
oh you got yourself oh yeah you hooked
him up
oh yeah
careful careful i don't want your butt
to get all wet
yeah you switched to a tiny one oh yeah
oh no
[Applause]
that [ __ ] is gold
okay i'm outta here i'm outta here i'm
in the splash zone comfy look at hannah
hell yeah look at her hell yeah
watch the tip of your jacket look at the
atheias in the woods i mean you really
don't even need it
[Applause]
he's covering his bones
[Applause]
okay so we cut the tail end of that but
they were running and laughing and
having the most
funnest time i was going to say
something else you don't know what oh
wait so it's even
don't know what the back is in disbelief
is it cold
yeah it's just water
look at the population water
don't pop out of falling too
yeah
don't papa fall into i'll follow with
you okay
no i'm falling with
you it sounds like you're saying that
you're he's have to do it again oh he's
gonna jump on me we'll do it together
yeah that's what it sounds like
he wants you to do it by yourself right
okay here what a good song
okay look okay look pop up you're a good
son thank you for the great idea okay
take out my stuff okay
electricity no that's true you're right
okay but go away we i don't want to get
splashed
[Applause]
what did i could do reenact it this is
like
boys boy gig boy gang boy gang what's
that
you gonna do it again let me see let me
see hey what happened show everybody
what happened hey there's no water there
hey there's no water there you cheater
no there's water over there there's no
water where you're at yeah pretend like
you did it again what happened
[Applause]
let's show me
oh i'm sorry okay we're done
did you have fun
it is cold now we haven't even walked
half a mile just like you know it wasn't
half a mile
not yet
well this is pretty cool this is really
cool oh wait what kind of naked can i
record you
underwear so joe talked himself in
nobody told him to ah
you're doing this next
it's not cold it's not cold you can do
it are we gonna do a cold punch i'm down
are you down kinda
let's go let's go
let's go guys it's so cold just dunk
full dog don't think about it dunk dunk
dunk will disappear
good job uh-oh it's happening
look at mama yay
it's happening hey
it's happening
okay he's not wearing underwear oh whoa
look at mama whoa there she goes
good job go go go
okay
three two one
oh my goodness
good job
good job that's awesome
hey monkey look at the big wind oh my
goodness
it's not wendy
you're not scared no more yeah
good job so proud of you dude that
smells like fresh air it smells like
fresh air now
after an hour
we are finally
sitting so hard
[Music]
the food
look at this
look at this and then tyka's cute little
okay so disclaimer not even this camera
but just
i messed up i meant to put dressing in
here and i spilled it all over his food
but it didn't get on his food so we're
good
papa's got oh i think it's coming
i got pork tenderloin and you know um no
this is i got thick pork katsu okay and
then this is
i forgot the name of it but it's like
it's like it's just eggs
if you know what oyakodon is it's like
uh it's got chicken i mean it's got egg
it's got sauce it's got onions i like
the sauce here we got you the sauce
oh and the clam misos
okay i'm sorry i want to apologize to
you taika because i skipped you i talked
to everybody and what they ordered and i
didn't ask you and you let me know
really quickly okay ready
monkey what did you order
okay enjoy
baby